if you've been victimized you're naive
and you've been victimized the way out
of that is to no longer be naive and to
no longer be victimized and that means
that you you see this reflected in the
Harry Potter idea for example that the
reason that Harry Potter can withstand
Voldemort is because he's got a piece of
them or he's been touched by it and the
way that you the way that you keep the
Psychopaths at Bay is to develop the
inner psychopath so that you know one
when you see one right and then but
that's a voluntary thing it's so it's
like a it's like a a set of tools that
you have at your disposal which is full
knowledge of evil